christine is with us in Salt Lake City
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Christine thanks for taking my call
sure what's up okay has apparently a
unique situation
my husband's employment was restructured
about a year ago and due to the nature
of how they get paid we knew that we'd
go hmm four to six months without seeing
an income which he has fluctuating
income so rather than just $1,000
mergency fund we have a three to four
months so that we can pay ourselves
federally every month and then that
refills when he gets paid unfortunately
that's gone most of the year and we've
been able to write it out but when the
employer started realizing how that it
was and some people were drawing from
401ks and other things they offer they
didn't offer they gave everyone a $5,000
advance you didn't have an option of
turning it down it was given but the
repayment is expected we also have
insurance premiums that the employer
covered and has been carrying and those
are being repaid as income comes back my
question is do we put those premiums are
those debts to the employer in their
place within our snowball or do they
take a priority kind of like the IRS
would so that we don't offend employment
offend we don't want to do anything like
if they fall into our snowball they're
number six and number eight so they're
down a little ways and getting paid off
but do they is they not have a repayment
schedule no they do not
they loans you money with no terms
correct at this point there's no
interest being charged on it they've
been carrying that because it's taken a
lot longer to get payments coming back
to some client
do for a living he's an attorney how
large a law firm is this they're a
pretty good size I used how an attorney
goes months and months and months
without making money because it's
considered a merit-based income so we're
paid on Commission and some of the
clients that they work with can take up
to six months to pay their bills so he's
brand-new mmm the firm is yes well it's
now a year old but my husband's been
working as an attorney for nine years
going on ten No and so what did he what
is he normally make in a year
last year was a hundred before taxes and
so yeah if he's not gonna get paid for
six months to a year why didn't he just
start his own practice he's not
comfortable doing that at this point I'm
not comfortable working without getting
paid
he is getting paid we've gotten paid for
the last three months sounds like this
law firm is dramatically
undercapitalized it feels that way for a
spousal perspective no I think that's a
math perspective yeah it's a spousal
perspective yeah so I'm not worried
about when I'm gonna repay these jokers
I've just put them in the debt snowball
when you get to him you get to them but
the I am worried about his career yeah
there's not that there's a lot of red
flags and flares going off and bombs
dropping around this story that they're
scary because you know if he was in a
specific type of law with one perfect
client or something and it was you know
and he's making 300 grand a year but you
know they only you know they only draw
down on this client twice a year or
something I would
say go let's go restructure the payment
terms with the with the client but but
it sounds like their business model is
screwed I'm concerned about that yeah I
mean I we work with attorneys all the
time I mean it's not I mean not only as
as their customer but also you know
coaching them on their personal finances
and I just don't know any that make no
money for six months that's just very
very weird so I'm concerned about that I
would but as far as the answer to your
question where would I put the
unsolicited advance that is
interest-free I would put it at in the
debt snowball where it belongs and if
they get offended about that they're the
ones that advanced it with no terms
there's no term sheet on this they
didn't say you have to pay this back in
six months they didn't say do you want
this they just issued the check and this
is just strange strange very strange so
yeah I'm not worried about whether
they're offended because I'm getting
ready to leave them anyway if he this
doesn't turn around hey that you know
couple a couple more months of this crap
and you guys really need to make a
decision